citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to watch the Mandalorian episode
dose today of course joined by John John
Howard Johnson ah John is John and this
is the John Michael how was Michael I'm
Michael yes he is I Love Lamp guys
follow MJ tesler on Instagram and
Twitter today thank you so much for
being here our Star Wars Aficionado as
we call them around these parts of the
rejection expert I am man you got to
work on that a little bit ladies and
gentlemen leave a like for Michael he
used the force to leave a like subscribe
click that notification Bell because we
are obviously covering this weekly and
full length Reaction watch long as we
sync up with your own copy of the
Mandalorian available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page thank you to
all who have joined so far her support
is astronomical and I'm Michael yes you
are it's not sponsored by them I always
got one in my hand so if you guys want
to get yourself some g-fuel today you
know 20 off promo code reject Nation I
drink these religiously it's a part of
my religion get it get it is the way G
fuel is a part of my religion you remove
the can from your hand your exercise
[Laughter]
[Music]
tattooing it's tattooing
shot first
trying to push it back out in the street
you heard him pitch right no no no no no
no no no no no
drive a hard bargain Peli Moto let's say
two months
don't settle your snout I'll put a rush
on it
you know I do have a life big holiday I
have big plans it's never even been to
space it's the anniversary of the Death
Star
hey tell the job was rodian left or a
life day let's get this thing back
together again quickly before he sees
you put those parts back on the speeder
paint them so they look different here
you go
[Music]
where's my guy
he is
you had a leap like a Lerman huh Luke
Skywalker did was that his first word
I think he's talking to me did you hear
that he said he simply no he didn't
I'm looking for a replacement IG memory
circuit oh hey Grandpa they haven't made
those for a while
I bet
so good I think you should buy this
beauty here
I need a Droid that can explore ahead of
me and test the atmosphere make sure
it's safe to breathe you're
could be piloting starfighters across
the Galaxy
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you
this for half the price
it's sugar tree is a little fragile I
thought you said it was built for
adventure
[Music]
I love the second life of R5 right now
so with you Pele Moto all right kid you
ready for an adventure
you know what they're celebrating
but yeah happy bunta guys
a mine
same but it was once green and beautiful
back when the songs were written the
cosmos it's Mandalore the Homeworld of
our people I've never been there either
I grew up there
on that Moon
Concordia wow nice that's kalavala where
we visited Boca Town a Mandalorian has
to understand maps and know their way
around you'll never be lost I love
teacher Ninja
Force grade on a curve
this poor R5 Droid
two
wow
this is gorgeous breathtaking from the
surface we won't be able to communicate
with anyone out of atmosphere down here
we're completely cut off from the rest
of the Galaxy
foreign
don't worry nothing bad will come of
that
water has been so much build up to going
here finally our five you ready I'm
gonna need you to scout ahead and
analyze the atmosphere
[Laughter]
[Music]
take an air sample of the ruins below
this R5
don't be a baby
[Laughter]
I don't like this we've got a bad
feeling about this
don't disappear yep
I'll go get them
damn this is beautiful
don't worry kid I'll be right back
hey Miss Lazarus emotional and physical
atmosphere of this place yeah right
[Music]
apparatus sounds like Vader
wow good cousin ballon's down there
somewhere whoa
The Time Machine
come on buddy work with it
nice
damn peace best car weapons they have
probably yeah
[Music]
or five
oh buddy man was gonna take his helmet
off again
I'm sorry
oh
well at least I'm here to get you back
to the ship
[Music]
no he's so happy
the charts were wrong huh the atmosphere
is breathable what else were they lying
about oh Katan was right Mandalore is
not cursed
entire religion
I should call her and apologize
too quiet
that's the Civic Center oh good and then
the Performing Arts Plaza is just down
there
awesome
I guess the city was domed once upon a
time
I love this episode yeah this is so cool
so tense right now sci-fi dread
this is so freaking cool Baboo freaking
cool
uh we go we're gonna go back there
another extinct but I feel like we might
see a mythosaur that's what I was
thinking too that's the balrog
what are those you know what those are
I don't recognize them they're not dank
ferricks
dankest ferrets out here
how many more down there
whoa
oh
what what is this uh that's
one of those Purge droids
oh wait no is that something different I
don't know oh damn there's a total I in
there it's a Star Wars Dalek
huh it looks like a bug
oh that feels like a person's in there
this little Krang
what the hell what
oh God I don't like this it's like an
intelligent xenomorph yeah
Android organic Android thing
ugh
what the hell is that it kind of reminds
me of in the unknown regions there's a
species called the grisk that is like
the secret big bad in the Beyond maybe
they're after best car in the unknown
regions
do you think grogu
come on buddy whoa
[Music]
whoa whoa dude
ambulance movie yeah
it's gonna be grogu and a bunch of other
little way more spikes it's like Mario
I want this to be a ride yeah
damn who directed this episode
[Laughter]
my man come on R5
[Music]
oh and he knew where the planet was
oh my God Boca tanzanus show up to help
yo Majesty you've been sitting on this
chair for six months an unscheduled
visitor
thank you
why does anyone respect my schedule
these trailer shots
I want to be left alone
what happened to him help a spoke at 10
your only hope download the Astromech
find out where they were
you know where they
were
those mandalorians that I make a ship
I way prefer this because I feel like an
earlier season Boca town would have just
randomly been there Save the Day
ah I got a little smile on your face
happy to be home home sweet home
yeah wow there's the Dome
get pelimoto in here
it didn't always look like this
yeah I heard
what face is that even there's a lot of
unprocessed trauma right there it's a
woman's face you judgmental prayer
okay okay kid I'm gonna need you to
guide me to him can you do that
this is the parrot but I didn't know I
needed
ask your chance to take the dark saver
of Lucas what's the worst that happens
our planet gets genocided again
I mean if you've withstood one genocide
textures on everything yeah I love the
glassing of a planet that obsidian look
I love her hips
look at that Star Wars hourglass God
[Music]
my family ruled it all
says Goku controlling that now
you can eat one I know that you're
frightened
but I need you to guide me to him
man up
I heard you
take it back nice
[Laughter]
part of me hopes Kroger never learns to
actually speak I feel like we're gonna
start seeing some words here and there I
knew quite a few Jedi you know there was
a time we actually got along quite well
fought side by side
[Music]
nope
oh you're good
nicely done oh man
he is nice
did you think your dad was the only
Mandalorian
those are alamites
and we were their next meal
if they survived
I wonder what else might have to
go
drain you of your human oil
is that a spit
it could be
what are they pumping out
oh it affects best car
oh there it is
[Music]
oh
oh nice oh look how comfortable yeah man
that's awesome
dad can you hear me yes
you gotta be flipping kidding oh no it's
gonna get the bigger body
behind you yeah
oh
my God she's so good with it oh she had
it for a while yeah
take that module and destroy it
give me back my dark saber
you can have my blood
what happened
I saved your life gave you some
penicillin you were right
Mandalore is not cursed
was I
nothing to cling to but ashes what is
this
you've never eaten POG soup
no
can you appreciate the irony
you should rest I'll get you back to my
ship soon enough
I must continue to the minds of
Mandalore so that I may be redeemed
I honestly think that it's adorable that
you actually believe these children's
stories without the Creed what are we
our people are scattered like stars in
the galaxy the Creed is how we survived
I can't go with you until I fulfill my
obligation I will take you
wow we can bathe together
don't thank me until you see them Living
Waters
it's gonna be an Ayahuasca trip I wonder
if there's anybody down there the Empire
set out to punish us to wipe away our
memory it must pain you to see it like
this after witnessing its beauty
that's understaffing your own kind fight
one another time and time again killing
each other for reasons too confusing to
explain it
made us weak
huh maybe you shouldn't have joined
Death Watch then
problem with all these different sects
of your religion can't come to an
agreement I was part of the royal family
the rituals were all just theater for
our subjects
they loved watching the princess recite
the Mandalorian tenants as her father
looked on proudly
your father sounds like an interesting
man
he died defending Mandalore
this is the way
[Music]
we're gonna bring up your dead sister
The Living Waters
I want you to get the full tour
according to ancient folklore the mines
were once a mythical lair
yep it is from these legends that the
skull Signet was adopted and became the
symbol of our planet oh man
this is it
take it all off but the helmet yes
hey you might get your wish
I swear on my name
oh
and the words of the Creed shall be
forever forged in my heart oh no
[Music]
is it really
oh wow
he's definitely bathing
wow what a great shot great shot yeah
James Cameron did this episode
what the
his armor was just so heavy
that's twice she's had to save him
yeah uh man oh man we're not ready POV
yeah
oh
my God no way oh that is insane
a tease at the scale yeah
oh wow
damn it who's Rachel Morrison I don't
know give her a raise
seriously have we seen her director
credit before I don't know that was
great wow yeah that was terrific love
the mood I didn't think
we would get that I mean I thought it
earlier but for some reason in the
moment I was like maybe not yeah sure
enough given up
will that uh
that was a great episode that was a
really really great episode
God
continues to subvert expectation I love
that they credit the somebody pointed
that out they credit the stunt actors
who actually do Mando now oh good yeah
it's those last two names there who
cares they're not Pedro Pascal's voice
he's a busy guy it's all about those few
minutes Pedro spends in the booth
man yeah that was that was phenomenally
executed it was it was so well done yeah
I I loved the
the direction they're going with Boca
tan because I can't quite tell where it
is I still I don't think it's what we
think uh but what do you mean I don't
think that Bo could now anything you
think is going to be wrong that's not
the thought you were thinking I have
several thoughts what am I wrong about I
don't think Bo's gonna be the villain no
no no nor do I I think they're going to
have something where there will be
it's going to be like a cobra Kai
situation is what I think is going to go
down John Katan Crees is coming where
nowhere they they are going to have a
difference of ideologies and they will
butt heads but they have to reunite men
but eventually yeah they are gonna see
that they are the thing that will bring
Unity to it so did his evil thing and Bo
katana's Miyagi dose yeah or one or the
flipping around doesn't matter which one
but yeah the one of the two that's what
I think that's where they're headed with
it where it seems like they could be on
the brink of like fighting amongst each
other but they're going to realize that
ultimately that's not the key to a
greater threat uh no I I completely
agree I mean uh I I appreciated the the
subtle Nuance of of lore
um subtle there's a lot well I mean it
was when it comes to Mandalorian Lord
you could just well they didn't put on a
40-minute YouTube
that's what I'm saying uh I thought it
was it was really casually well done but
like the way that Beau looked at Din
when he was in the water was just like I
respect your commitment and tenacity
but also there might be something to
this this is a beautiful moment yeah I
mean she washed away judgment in that
moment and I I think began to see a
future that has otherwise
the idea of a future for Mandalore felt
extinct for her and I think in Den she
sees a future
um and I I I'm really really excited I I
just keep wondering have we not even met
our big bad yet
um
I'm not sure because what's cool about
these two episodes together
I kind of feel like they could have
they're tonally in pace so different and
I get why they're two separate episodes
but they could have prepared them both
on the same day yeah glad they didn't
because that would have been a lot of
editing for me
thank you Disney glad they did it but
did it just for granted when they do
that I'm like Jesus Christ it's
gonna be a long long night
um but
um what's what's different already
structurally is it doesn't feel like
mission of the week that eventually
becomes tethered together
uh but in the last few episodes like how
the first two seasons were like this is
immediately after the first episode and
it's it feels very serial and even where
this ends off it feels very much like
this whole all the episodes are going to
be way more connected and very focused
yeah exactly where I really loved the
structure of of the first two seasons I
love the the red because it's like the
missions are well Justified like well I
need to survive so I need to take on
some missions and then how they come
together I think it's really cool but to
see these two back to back uh it does
put it in a different lens for how this
can progress and I really just want to
say this I think this is Katie
sackhoff's best work she's done thus far
uh as being live action Boca tan it's a
it's a tough character to adapt to live
action
um it was so
it was
I mean Beau is such a uh in in Clone
Wars
I'm trying to say what I know you're
thinking not what I'm thinking I'm I'm
saying that she's a complicated
character and has been from the first
time that we saw her
um I mean first time we met Beau in
Clone Wars she was on the wrong side
yeah
um and I think has always been a very
impulsive quick to react character uh
and I appreciate that going back to
Mandalore facing her mistakes we're
seeing just a really interesting nuanced
character
um that is is making for just like great
storytelling yeah
are you no no not at all do you think
but what if uh it's not possible being
on the reject there's definitely
definitely reaching
all right I mean I I feel like they were
indicating to us throughout this episode
that there are other survivors
of a Mandalorian background who may have
survived and may still be on Mandalore
um do you think that's a possibility do
you think there's definitely yeah I mean
that was the whole point of what bocatan
was saying with like what else could
have survived and you do see that
there's these other there are there are
qualities about this that felt like the
most obvious one to note is you have
some like aliens uh but also this did
have like when you when you call them
like the second time warlocks was like
that's exactly what I was thinking too
was very much in like an H.G Wells type
of situation yeah if you guys haven't
seen the time machine watch The Guy
Pierce one that's a superior version
that's the version Orlando Jones Jeremy
Irons boy that's the one to go with uh
but no it did it did resonate in that
regard uh
because you know like there is this Gap
in time that we just haven't seen of
what happened here so even though it's
not a time travel episode we have jumped
forward with if you if you take the time
with clone wars and Rebels uh anything
to do with Mandalore that's not only you
just skip ahead like oh it's all gone
now it's all it's all destroyed it's the
ruins so there is a sense of of like a
time travel quality to it only because
of the fact that there is this chunk
that we're missing that eventually
Kathleen Kennedy's gonna be like produce
that show we got to see it now we got to
fill in all the gaps I mean all of it
needs to be visuals
Nothing To The Head yeah if there's a
millisecond that is unaccounted for in
Canon yeah make it a show then making a
shower movie well I think that's what's
kind of neat
um like who's gonna play Young
that's a great question
no I mean I I do agree that we will see
that
um either in the form of flashbacks or
in uh future animated property yeah it's
gonna be expensive um
uh no yeah I think animation is probably
the the right move for that
um
no I mean that that period between
Rebels and now like yeah things really
hit the fan on Mandalore
um I'm I'm really interested to see if
these was ever left you know yeah are
they okay what's what's going what's
going on that we haven't seen them or
heard from them or or do they even know
the war is over like I wonder if uh uh
it's gonna be like like the Japanese
World War II soldiers that like in the
1970s they were like still trying to
catch some of the guys on the island who
didn't believe that they surrendered
um which would be really cool to see
like
um Japanese like fenrao Fen Rao from uh
Rebels who was one of the Mandalorian
protectors who was you know friends with
Beau uh I just think it'd be really cool
to see
what happens to the mandalorians who
still think the fight's going on uh and
I feel like that could be an interesting
Star Wars loves to pull from World War
II or yeah so I mean yeah there's a lot
of interesting aspects this can go down
but I I do want to just appreciate like
what the episode in and of itself did
because this was more because remember
last last week that Premiere episode
of saying that this feels like the most
light-hearted and hopeful mandalorians
ever been and start off that way when
I'm so used to be kind of being darker
yeah and then the second episode is this
is more the Mandalorian that I know and
love because I really like the last
episode uh a lot but this was this is
more my cup of tea when it comes to the
Mandalorian and it was paced so well it
was filled with a lot of tension and it
had life day I know John Favre really
loves that
does he does I don't know why he loves
you so much because the holiday special
is the greatest Star Wars content that
was ever created is that the same R5
Droid from I think a new hope it's just
been kicking around this long yeah I
mean and to think how different that's
the what if series I want to watch what
if R5 was picked instead of R2 uh we
would have had a whole other Series yeah
sure it would never have been as popular
yeah it would have just been Luke going
to Tachi station to pick up some power
converters yeah
but what does he do with them is the
question but what'd you think of the set
design John I love the set design I
thought this did really nicely to I've
always thought the Mandalorian has
looked really good in the way it
realizes things but you know we live in
a world now where the volume especially
is just a much more noticeable thing and
everybody is a little more aware that
that happens and here I
I found myself having the sort of the
thought you want to have where you're
like this doesn't look like the volume
you know this looks really tangible
tangible yeah and I love just yeah
getting to know these ruins and like
kind of like you said like it has all
that stuff that you love from the
Mandalorian but this also kind of felt
like it did progress the tone the style
because you are just sort of drinking in
the air all of the air of you know this
this worn down decimated space and uh I
loved the discovery of that the fun that
led to you get these creatures and
things like that and and even though
there are a lot of desolate and rendered
planets that we visit in a show like
this this felt like a a place with even
just seeing it here intimately in this
one episode it already has this this
care it feels like a character unto
itself yeah there's an architectural
Wonder still yeah well I think that's
one of my favorite parts of like the
Nuance of Mandalorian culture and lore
is that like they're not just Epic
Warriors they're also artists like
they're also Architects like Sabine
wren's
like when he's introduced you know
you're expecting to see this like great
Mandalorian warrior and it turns out
he's just like an art nerd and I I think
exploring that's kind of what like the
armor represents that too I mean
everything everything about them is very
there is a a a traditional Warrior
artistic style to them yeah I mean I I
think that's why they made such
wonderful Rivals to the the Jedi
um because it mirrors that kind of
the The Art of War and culture and like
that Samurai feeling of you know these
different Clans each have these these
symbols that represent them and and this
ideology is ancient
um and you know I think it's neat that
what was Star Wars Legends is slowly
becoming
like and and I love even for example
when they introduced the idea of the
mythosaur and kind of like gave us a
little contextual background I love that
the mandalorians understanding of what
happened is just as like questionable as
our understanding of what happened
because it's Legends for us too yeah um
and it's history through multiple lenses
and perspectives yeah well and I think
it's kind of neat uh it makes the
characters
uh a little bit like us well you know
they used to ride them at the source too
Conquest so I'm thinking that if they if
they can somehow pull that mythosar out
and they could use it to fight whatever
big Baddie and not just big Baddie but
think of the symbol of yeah yeah but I'm
talking because the dark savior
absolutely because canonically speaking
the helmet of Mandalore
was the symbol and then the dark saber
was stolen by Clan V's love from the
Jedi Temple and then that became the
symbol and now the dark saber has like a
lot of just bad vibes around it like
it's the sword that killed like energy
around me
yes it's kind of weird that the dark
Sabers they have dark energy but uh I
feel like it would be really interesting
to to have you know as you create the
legend of this new Mandalore and this
new leader who I really feel didn't yarn
is like the especially the fact that
they did make you know Canon and clear
that he is from the Mandalore system
um I thought that was really like coming
from Concordia uh as where he was from I
thought was a really nice like oh great
he's like actually Mandalorian and not
like a foundling from somewhere totally
random
um it's not a randolorian yeah a random
Lori
well I mean he still could have been the
foundling who was raised there
well well no no no you have me doubting
myself he was really young I spent a lot
of time in therapy to get over as much
doubt in you would mind
uh no yeah because of mandalorians like
a nationality it's not a race
it's kind of like being Jewish religion
act like being Jewish yeah no that's
exactly speaking as the Jew in the group
um that's exactly what it is it's both a
race of people but well the interesting
thing is the ancient mandalorians if
we're going by like Legends if there was
a race that was separate of humans and
humans ended up becoming the majority
but Mandalorian as a culture was
something that was slowly adapted yeah
um so the Mandalorian race is as as an
actual race went extinct and if you
believe in Legends which I do they come
from Coruscant
um now you don't believe in Legends Greg
that's something yeah well it's a tall
tale Mike uh well you know uh yeah I'm
I'm just really really excited to figure
out what is the unifying event that will
bring the mandalorians back together
um and we know
you know uh that at least by the time of
the sequel Trilogy that mandalorians are
still around in the galaxy
because they were
one of the flags at Maz kanata's Palace
yeah I remember that you don't remember
that's the only thing I remember I I
remember watching the trailer on the
real rejects pausing and being like
that's the Mandalorian flag sure hope I
get to talk about that one day on the
real rejects I mean it was just like you
were here in the room for a second yeah
crazy uh no I don't remember any of that
uh
yeah I I know you don't love me getting
too excited about the other Star Wars
shows
um because you want to focus on the
present and be here in this show
um but I do really love the idea I hate
it I know you hate it but I do really
love this idea of you know uh the the
person who gave bocaton the dark saber
Sabine Wren there's a character from
Rebels
um is like definitively going to be a
big part of the Ahsoka series which will
it sounds The Soca series sounds like
Rebels continued live action what should
a Time Jumper which I feel like will
have a uh would be really useful for
them to have an army of mandalorians at
their side oh definitely no so there's
the the rebel the Soco show I just view
as live action Rebels I'm like great
that's what it sounds like to me
whatever I hear about oh that sounds
like every character from Rebels is
returning basically I've sold sold uh
yeah I mean I know thrawn had a
my favorite Star Wars characters loved
Mandalorian culture uh and found it
really really fascinating so yeah I'm
just excited to see how the dots connect
um and the tone of this like
this is obviously so different from
Andor and I feel like that was a big
complaint that I saw from the last
episode is that and or kind of changed
the game of what we expected of Star
Wars content
um but like Anders this like great World
War II spy Thriller this is like Lord of
the Rings of yeah sure and it's
interesting like existing within the
same universe but having these like
wildly different genres that exist
within that you know franchise well I
feel like that's something that could be
happening you know we'll see as the
season unfolds but I I don't expect this
show to become and or have that level of
concern with what its allegory is doing
necessarily but I do feel like
especially seeing this season take a
shape that feels a little more directly
serial as you pointed out uh could lend
itself and they're also like they're
back on Mandalore they're they're
confronting directly the culture the
religion Etc and I feel like you could
unpack that over the course of this
especially as you know the the more they
bring this place back the more
legitimacy the more dispelling of all
the the myths and things like that the
more people are going to be eyeing it
and the more conflicts are going to
arise and the more the sectarian you
know debacle that partly ripped this
place apart is going to come back into
The Fray so I feel like you can get that
but at the same time yeah I don't I
don't expect this to just go full and or
and I don't think it should because this
should be a bit of a swashbuckling
Adventure
um but yeah this feels like something I
love the way this ended too because this
ends in a very definitive like no we're
going to continue this next time this
isn't over by a long shot and uh that's
exciting in and of itself and and as a
bonding experience for these two very
different points on a plane you know
these two poles as DIN and and Bo you
know are sort of forced into the
situation together I think there are a
lot of interesting opportunities for
subtext uh you know that can still be
fun I think we're just gonna go to
tattooing and follow Jawas next week
let's do it do a do a bottle episode
with just Pele in the drawers yeah this
no this whole this all seems like it's
about them realizing the Grays in their
belief system that you know vocatan's
really was constantly like you are so
wrong about everything and then in jar
is like my Creed is what it's all about
and then you know he shows him he's like
oh this place isn't actually cursed
and then she's seeing his commitment to
this baptism and as she's Rising I don't
know why the myth of soldiers was like
you're coming down here all right you
can leave now
the myth is our Beast even her seeing
that it's like wait a minute there must
be some truth to these things I've
always called fairy tales yeah and so
what we're gonna see here is I yeah it
sounds like we're headed towards a union
yeah and I'm I'm excited for that but
you know for a union to happen you do
need some type of thing and that's
what's so wonderful about
Star Wars as as a whole has always been
so definitively good and evil and I feel
like
mandalorians in so many ways represent
us and like the real world and the fact
that like at some point you know you
have to like not to throw out your
Enlightenment era philosophy or anything
but like you know uh I may not agree
with a single word you say but I'll
defend to the death you're right to say
it and this idea of like coming together
all of Voltaire and and figuring out how
do we co-exist and recognize that like
whatever we are and that's many facets
is more important to keep together than
it is to just have our individual
sentiment yeah uh be kept alive so it's
exciting well I think when
um ninjarin's people are riding the bus
they should be in the back yeah they are
not pure mandalorians and they should be
treated as such yeah I think that's how
you do it that way you can coexist this
is the way
that is not the way it is this is the
way get on come on dude we outnumber you
so as well so
buddy you shouldn't say to the nice
Jewish boy in the corner uh no it's um
we view you like an equals that's what
we're willing to say to you yeah yes any
other nice Jewish boy we would not be
talking to yeah
well uh you're different I am you're one
of the good ones one of the cool Jewish
boys Michael how deep can we dig this
um right into the mines
we should wrap this up it's all
obviously also going towards grogu
becoming the ultimate Mandalore sure
about time we say that but will his
helmet have ear holes yes well that is
kind of the final if the mandalorians
can get over the differences between
each other
grogu represents that ultimate bridging
of the gap between the Jedi and the man
you start
it's fresh start yeah
until the next Mandalorian Civil War
20 years later there's too many
mandalorians out of control all these
emotions
and corner and integral Corners don't of
your religion I I feel like conflict is
insured well the lack of violence is a
sin which does spread a little bit of
chaos so ah well we're gonna do all
righty guys well what did you think
about this episode of the Mandalorian
leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe leave a like follow Michael
um who was our Neil deGrasse Tyson of
the Star Wars world right now I think
shoes to fill very big shoes yeah and
who do you do you think anybody is alive
and if so who what are they doing are
they okay I'd love to hear your thoughts
I'll respond let's do a pick
Michael since you left to talk can you
shout out pandemic Jones
pandemic Jones congratulations you are
the patron of the day thank you for your
support your love and especially
your money uh no we are so grateful you
make it really personal though oh I
don't want to just sound like you know
like some general oh you want to make it
personal it's a general thing pandemic I
know you've been going through a lot
lately you know with the government
being like you're over but sure you're
not over to me pandemic pandemic
when I go to sleep at night I often
think about
I wonder what Greg's editing right now
and I know when Greg's editing what he's
really thinking about is
thank God for him we're pandemic Jones
that that guy is single-handedly keeping
this channel going
and I I just want to say from the bottom
of my heart since Greg doesn't have one
anymore no
um thank you it's on the front of us
oh my God Jesus Christ no seriously uh
you know it's really easy to forget that
the real rejects uh are real people and
you know Greg is a great guy John is a
guy no yeah
and uh and I know that they as human
beings view you as their Eagle which
Speaking from experience is surprising
and unusual for them so I view you
higher than me I look up to you pandemic
Jones
I'm nothing you did it I did it do we
have to do the letter thing P for no no
please let me know if you're new
and only do Star Wars references when it
happens now P for uh Paz visla ah yes
the the big Mandalorian yeah yeah he was
here last week yeah who ate lots of
I was I was going to go for the
pantoines
yes Star Wars I get it they could be the
creatures from this episode whose name
now eludes me
and he spelled auxiliary n is
for Naboo and one star okay okay
everyone stop stop talking D is hidden
[Music]
laughs